hey everyone this is Kevin from the test
website comm and today we're in round
seven of our coverage of the 2018 Tata
Steel tournament our competitors today
whites played by Magnus Carlsen the
world champion number one player in the
world he's undefeated so far in this
tournament five draws and one win coming
into round seven he's still a full point
behind the leader who has three wins so
just having a phenomenal tournament Ben
magnus carlsen a lot of rounds to play
so he knows just keep doing what he's
doing if you get to win here he can keep
himself in contention
his opponent 23 year olds from China she
is the only female competitor and that
is e fan if you're not too familiar
she's probably the second greatest
female player of all time extremely
talented player she's been the world
champion the woman world champion three
times already at just 23 years old
phenomenal chess player been spending a
lot more of her time focused on overall
play playing against women and men
trying to become not only the best woman
player in the world but the best player
in the world was so awesome for her
unfortunately she's not having the best
tournament that she would have liked she
has four losses in to draw so only one
point through six rounds she will be
going off no small task against the
world champion here so we'll start with
Magnus Carlsen pawns who see for not
something we normally see from Magnus
Carlsen pretty much 90% of the time
we're seeing pawn to e4 but decides to
change things up pawn to c4 pawn to e6
Knight c3 pawn down here to d5 pawn up
here to d4 and Aoife and decides to go
ahead and decline so we get into the
Queen's game to climb line instead of
pawn taking here pawn to e3 to take back
the pawn besides now we'll go and play
Queens gambit declined line Magnus
Carlsen decides to go for the exchange
variation where he takes on d5 after the
Knight takes then we see pawn to e3 this
is another one of those times where was
not expecting Magnus Carlsen to play
this many times in the exchange
variation you'll see white play pawn to
e4 and then an exchange happens right
here pawn recaptures on c3 has it back
bird pawn on c3 but white really has
controlled the center of the board with
the pawns Magnus Carlsen decides to go
for something different solidifies pawn
chain with pawn to e3 and then pawn c5
trying to break up the center control
the board that Magnus Carlsen has Bishop
to d3 and then we see in exchange pawn
takes and now we see the knight come
down here to c3 pawn recapture so my
name is Carlson not quite the the pawn
structure I thought he'd come out with
does have a backward pawn here on c3 but
all in all this tends to look like
something magnus carlsen has prepared
for did not spend much time on his moves
so you could tell he has a game plan and
he is executing to that gameplan even
decides to play Queen to c7 just giving
the Queen involved into the game also
attacking this pawn here on a c3 Magnus
Carlsen responds bishop to d2 now we see
black play Knight to d7 you don't want
to bring it here to c6 blocking your
queen and the light square bishop it's
not gonna be moving anytime soon so
decides to go ahead and play the Knight
to d7 can also swing it to the King side
of the board if she wants to
Queen to g4 this is pretty interesting
for Magnus Carlsen he has the safe route
and that's Knight to f3 this seems
pretty normal castle on the King side
develop is normal but that's not the
game plan Queen to g4 very aggressive
and says I don't want you to play Bishop
to e7 which is the most common move
castle on the Kings side get some safety
this stops that Queen to g7 would be the
move from Magnus Carlsen so this puts a
halt to anything and the e fan was
trying to do forced to play now Knight
to f6 Queen's gonna move Queen comes
back here to g3 can't really hold on to
the pressure something like Queens who
g5 is just gonna be met by pawn to h6
eventually the Queen is going to move it
could come back and just retreat to e3
but Magnus Carlsen seems to be fine with
an exchange on g3 and that's exactly
what black does Queen takes on g3 we
have the exchange and then this rook is
open semi opened file to control this
h-file and usually after you see
something like this the Queen's come off
the board much more likely that
both sides are not gonna be castling
usually we want to have your kings
involved into the center of the board
they are a very strong piece once they
can't be chased around with a strong
attack from a queen bishop down here d6
just getting involved into the game
Knight to f3 common place for this night
to come to controls the center pawn to
b6 opening at the door for the light
squared Bishop to come involved into the
game control this long light square
diagonal pawn to a4 starting to attack
on the Queen side Bishop to b7 pawn a5
some Magnus Carlsen just pushing up on
at the Queen's head the board he does
have both of his bishops eyeing down to
protect this pawn over here also has
this rook here on a1 King to e7 and then
King to e2 so both sides at the same
time say yes we will lose our right to
castle and let's just attack each other
as much as possible Knight down here to
e4 Bishop comes back to e1 Magnus calls
and not ready to exchange his Bishop
quite yet pawns who aged 6 this just
stops the move coming up here to g5 pawn
to c4 so you'll start to see Magnus
Carlsen just pushed a little bit more
and more trying to improve his position
he feels like he has a slight advantage
right now so he just needs to find the
best move every time and just push up
see if he can limit the moves that black
has on the board Knight comes back here
to f6 wasn't doing anything after the
bishop move not gonna be doing too much
here on the e4 square so decides to come
back
Bishop back here to c3 could have
decided to just keep doing the the same
dog-and-pony show but for now decides to
go ahead and bring the bishop down here
to e4 before the knight was down here
being protected by the bishop now the
bishop comes down here being protected
by the knight on f6 rook over here to b1
- Carlson says yeah if you want
exchanged bishops I'm fine with that
exchange I'm just gonna go ahead and
start getting my rooks over to the Queen
side the board so I can start an attack
with this pawn with both of the rooks
behind it protecting it even plays
Bishop takes on d3 completely fine
magnus carlsen he recaptures with his
King Knight back here to d7 a knight to
d2 rook to DA just trying to get involve
to the center of the board and that up
here to e4 semantics Carlson positioning
a little bit attacking the bishop right
here Bishop comes back here to c7 and
you start to see magnus carlsen pushing
his pieces making it very difficult for
a fan to really do anything has a
cramped position and just pushing as
much as possible so a bishop here to
before check King back to e8 and then
pushing on the King side here pawn to f4
we see rook over here to c8 trying to
control the center but Magnus Carlsen
has a lot of threats going on and black
just has to sit there and try to play
defense as best as possible pawn takes
the pawn recaptures and then the rook up
here to a7 always good to get your rooks
on your opponent's seventh rank if
you're white if you're black you can
imagine down here on the second rank I
just attacked so much material from your
opponent they're usually gonna have some
pawns on the seventh rank most people
haven't pushed all their pawns and in
this particular case you can see they
have two two minor pieces and two pawns
back there so a lot of material does
also thwart some of the squares that the
King can go to if these minor pieces
move Knight to b8 so really defensive
Knight here to be eight you can compare
that to this knight on e4 magnus carlsen
much more aggressive night it can get in
and start attacking some of the material
we're even right here knight on b8 not
doing too much except trying to control
some of the board and this is where
magnus carlsen is dangerous most people
when they're doing all their
calculations they're not thinking about
their opponent is just going to throw
and give their work away for a crazy
variation where they end up with a
slightly better position but that's
exactly what magnus carlsen does it
doesn't take much for him if he can just
see a slight improvement it does not
matter what material he has to exchange
he will do it that's exactly what he
found in the sequence he takes rook on
c7 rook takes the bishop rook recaptures
Knight up here to d6 check after the
King moves now Knight to f7 this is
attacking the rook here on a d8 rook to
c8 and then we have another check right
here after the King moves Bishop up here
to
six attacking the rook rook comes over
here to b7 you can see magnus carlsen is
pretty much forcing all of these moves
making it very very difficult gobbling
up some of these pawns on the board and
then pawn to c5 also another great move
the pawn can't take here the rook would
come up here and take on a b7 so that's
not going to work and so after the
knight comes down here to c6
then the the rooks able to come up here
to b6 Oh Magnus Carlsen gets the
material back in the form of pawns and
now he has a huge pawn advantage he has
a passed pawn here on the C file and he
can really start to push his advantage
black takes on b6 pawn recaptures and
now Magnus Carlsen has a the passed pawn
here on the B file with pawn b6 Knight
to d8 trying to bring the knight over
here - b7 stopping the pond from pushing
forward Magnus Carlsen Bishop c7 great
little outposts move from Magnus Carlsen
so tough for T fan to really deal with
this it does stop and protect this
square here on it b8 from black to bring
a piece right here just limits the
squares that black has to go to - real
options here from Black Knights who b7
stopping the pawn right now the other
one being the rook over here - AAA which
is exactly what black does trying to
bring the rook down here - the Queen's
had the board attack the King
potentially gobble up some material on
the King side of the board it's just so
tough for for black to come out of this
just so much pressure Magnus Carlsen has
on the board keen to see forth trying to
come over here protect the advantage
that Magnus Carlsen has on the Queen
side
Knight to b7 King up here to b5 a now
rook down to a - fine - Carlsen not
worried about too much place pawn to g4
he fantasizes better to play King to e7
than to take material back over here
pawn to g3 says yeah now if you want to
use a few extra moves to take this pawn
I'm completely ok with that I have a
good thing going with my position
Knight to a d6 we do see an exchange on
board and then Knight to c4 King back
here d7 king c5 just
I sold a little bit behind this night
here on a c4 rook to a situ pond up here
to f5 and then we see the pond
recaptures so managed Collison no longer
has the double ponds on the G file
doesn't have to worry about that rook
over here to f2 and then we see Knight
to d6 rook to g2 and this is sort of it
an interesting move as soon as this
Knight comes up here to d6 the king is
attacking it now mind you that the king
cannot take the knight right now because
it's protected by the king but this
starts to have some alarm bells go off
as far as what black can do on board one
of the options they now have is rook to
c2 now they would really like to protect
this pawn right here King to b5 makes a
lot of sense but you can see that losses
because the king is attacking the knight
so Knight takes on d6 so if we see the
most common move which would be king to
d5 you want to hold on to that Knight
makes sense to do that then work over
here to be to defending that and now
black has a chance on board because he
can start to move his material over if
we want to play King to c7 now and then
rook takes here on b7 the yes magnus
carlsen will have a pawn advantage but
that tends to look better at face value
here as far as what she can do but
decided to not do that instead plays
rook to a g2 and then the knight comes
down to e4 and you can see how different
this is the rook can't just come over
here to see to now check because the
King can easily protect this pawn
doesn't matter doesn't have to worry
about the king taking the night here on
a d6 so how different things are
once this Knight comes here to e4 black
comes over to a b2 now attacking the
pawn pawn to g4 from Magnus Carlsen
worked down here to b1 just maneuvering
a little bit night down here to d2
attacking the rook rook to h1 pawn to d5
so you can see Magnus Carlsen with
additional passed pawns just pushing
those any time you have passed pawns
rule number one
push the past pons h5 doesn't do too
much for for blacks position d6 just
pushing so hard to deal with and then we
see King to c8 being forced push back
the pond takes here on h8 if we see
instead of the king to see eights maybe
the pond takes on g4 it's not gonna go
well pawn to b7 that's why the king came
up to see a to try to stop that now rook
has to come up to h8 Knight to c4 rook
over here to be eight and then we see
Knight to e5 check it's all gonna be
very difficult for black to hold on to
this tonight after the king to c7 then
you could see the knight come to c6
preparing for the Pontic come up here or
you know some other thing happened then
I could take that so just all bad things
happen so decides in the game to go
ahead and play after pawn to d6 King up
here to g8 allows Magnus Carlsen to take
that pawn on h5 King up here to c6 which
is pretty safe Square it's gonna be
tough for black to attack this King
that's gonna take at least two moves to
attack that and by that time there's so
much managed Carlsen can do on the board
King here to b8 Knight up here to e4
after the rook takes the now Knight to
c5 making it even more difficult for
black to attack the King yes even does
have a passed pawn but you know here on
the g7 square not gonna do too much so
at the end of the day she decides to
resign in this position saw no way that
she could come out of this stopping both
of these pawns with the knight right
here it's just nice protecting both of
these pawns as they push forward and
then depending on where black goes that
the king could go to either side so very
very easy for manage Carlsen to convert
this so congratulations to him people at
the top won their game as well so he's
still a full point behind even though he
is undefeated with five drawls and two
wins but always good for him to get a
victory he still has
a lot of rounds left in this tournament
so he would look to continue his good
fortune but always nice to see 23 year
old Chinese women do extremely well in
this tournament we don't get a lot of
females in the master class so with one
of the top players in the world always
good to see her competing she's played
in this tournament before one of the
strongest players in the world so always
good to cover her games but thank you
guys so much for watching
round seven hopefully you guys are
enjoying coverage of the tournament and
I will be back tomorrow for round number
eight Thanks